president donald trump campaigning in
the silver state today
making it clear that nevada is a big
priority for him in this election
thank you so much for joining us tonight
at 11 o'clock i'm sasha loftis
the president held a rally in carson
city earlier this evening
orco mana joins us live near mccarran
international airport here in las vegas
where trump recently landed with more on
his efforts to win over voters
orco well sasha president trump landed
here at mccarran
just before 8 o'clock tonight you can
still see air force one there behind me
he will stay here in las vegas overnight
the president
rallying supporters up north today
saying he is the clear choice for voters
but the biden campaign says nevadans
should not buy into that message
sixteen days from now we're going to win
the state of nevada we're going to win
four more years in the white house
president donald trump stumping in the
silver state sunday just over two weeks
from election day
thousands of supporters cheering for the
president at his make america great
again rally at carson city airport
trump touting his accomplishments
focusing as he usually does on the
economy
we'll fully resume the nevada tourism
and hospitality industry which is
fantastic will come roaring back
and it will when you vote for me
prosperity will search
earlier sunday morning trump attended a
service at the international church of
las vegas
his visit to nevada comes as early
voting across the state gets underway
voting in this election is critical
state senator inviting campaign senior
adviser ivana cansella telling me voters
have the chance to change the direction
of this country
democrats continuing to criticize the
president's handling of the coven 19
pandemic and the economic fallout
the democratic national committee even
putting up these billboards across the
state including this one not too far
from trump tower in las vegas calling
the administration a failure
joe biden not only has a plan he has the
experience to make sure that we address
both facets of the pandemic what trump
has done is a disservice to families
across the country and especially here
in nevada
still president trump hopes he can count
on nevada in november
we will make america great again
get out and vote
now during his rally today president
trump mentioned that he's leading here
in nevada
but according to the latest cbs news
battleground poll trump is actually
six points behind biden reporting live
tonight orca mana 8 news now